The joe rogan experience.
Yup.
But that's the problem that we'd
forbidden stuff. It never works well.
It's also a Italian food and
wine seem to go hand in hand and,
and it's,
I think,
I mean did they used to be what they
drank because they were concerned with
getting sick.
Right.
And one of the best ways to not get sick
was to drink wine because, well, yeah,
the alcohol content would
keep the water from,
I mean like if you just
drink water all the time,
especially if it's sitting still, you
could get some bad fucking water. Right.
You can get bad water from
a lake. I mean, how many,
they didn't know Jack Shit
about parasites back then.
How many people got some terrible diseases
from drinking puddle water and Shit,
you know? Sure. A lot. Oh yeah. He just
find some water like, oh, we're thirsty.
Time to drink. And, or even at creek you
drink in a creek and you think like, oh,
this is a beautiful stream.
This is a clear water. Yeah.
But a beaver took a shit just a hundred
yards a match that you don't know about
it. You get what's called beaver
fever. That's what you're for real.
That's what they called Giardia. They call
it beaver fever. Yeah. That can be good.
Now it's terrible.
So they used to drink wine to prevent
what they would call traveler's disease
because people would take these,
those, what are those things called?
The leather things that they would
carry wine and I want to say flask,
but it's not a flask.
What are those?
Those those leather satchels I [inaudible]
I thought they use philosopher.
Dot. But I'm not sure. It
might be, there's a term,
it's like a leather bag and
it had like a on the end,
like a cork and he just drank from that.
And that's how they would hydrate. Yup.
People must have been
just hammered all day.
When you read the statistics of
how much people used to drink,
it's amazing that anything got done
because it's just people where that ain't
good morning through night and her, they
must have been horrific to each other.
Then just just to imagine like a whole
civilization that is a drunken bar at
1:00 AM angry drag. Yeah.
It's funny cause I never,
and I mean I've seen it
enough that I get it.
People get edgy and weird
where when they drink too much,
but I never got it because to me
it's like if I'm drunk he like,
that's when I'm happy. I want
to hug people. Why would I
want to be in a bad mood?
This is also this. Well you're a nice
guy. That's what it is that comes out the,
yeah, if you're a fucking asshole
you, she'll drunk. I see you.
Especially if you just barely keeping
that ass hole under the surface.
She's barely just want to try and stab
her but in club them and steal their
women and then you get a couple of
drinks in you and this, this is alcohol.
Alcohol is a great social lubricant thing.
It's great for releasing inhibitions
and letting people communicate with each
other more freely and have fun.
But it's also,
it removes doubt and that's not good.
Right?
I think Todd is critical.
Like doubt is one of the pieces
of the great puzzle, right? The,
the great puzzle has many ingredients
and one of those ingredients is doubt and
doubt is important.
You should look at anything you're about
to contemplate and go think about this.
When we think what could go wrong when
you get a couple of drinks, fuck it,
let's do it, let's go. And
then next thing you know,
you know you're on an Internet
meme. Hold my PR. Yeah, exactly.
We talked about that yesterday, like
some of the most more ridiculous ones,
but there's so many of those out there
and almost all of them I have to do with
alcohol. [inaudible] right. And I
think what you are saying about dove,
there's a great Alan Watts, the guy who
polarizes an and that weighs in Mendota,
that stuff. He had these good eighth line,
he called it the wisdom of insecurity.
You know,
these ideas that had real careful,
there's always don't diary
not being dogmatic and which
doesn't mean the problem
is then people take that concept to Fairen
that donating to having no bowls and
not being able to pick a stand.
That's not a solution either.
That's the other side of the problem.
But there's a sweet spot in
between where you can take stances,
but they are careful stances.
They are sent stances that
are very willing to be
changed at the drop of a dime
if you show the good evidence to
to change them. You know? He's,
that to me is what intellectual honesty
looks like, you know? Yeah, I agree.
I think it's good to be aware
of all the possibilities.
I used to tell people that when
I was a teaching taekwondo,
like people that wouldn't compete
if they were really, really nervous.
I'd be like,
the really smart people are really
nervous because you're aware of all the
possibilities of everything
that could go wrong.
The people that aren't worried about
it at all, they're usually dumb.
There's that. But also to me, there
are some people, like I look at,
some of the people were able
to keep it together in this,
like kind of like Chuck Lee died,
right?
Take a nap right before
a fight kind of thing.
I can't tell by looking at those guys
and just be like, you know something.
I don't know what,
you know,
there's something there that you're
doing confidence for sure. I mean,
chuck had been knocking
people unconscious for many,
many years and he knew exactly what to
do and I think knew he was good at it.
There's that for sure. And I think there's
the other side is knowing that, okay,
if I have decided to do it, fear is
not going to help me now. You know,
if that would me to make
decisions solely or,
but right now he's now going to
help me. So let's figure out, man,
he was hilarious. There's um, my
girlfriend fights MMA professionally.
You notice that? Yeah, she's wise.
I've been paying attention to uh,
your escapades online. She's,
she's crazy. She's crazy.
She said she literally at the
Chuck Liddell mode where she,
she took a nap right before
a fight and you know,
like 45 minutes before you have to
wake her up and going like, hey Randy.
And she's all like, okay,
ready to roll. And I'm like,
I would not sleep for a week prior out.
You managed to keep it together
like kids do. I used to do that.
I used to sleep before fights.
It's good. That's awesome.
Yeah, but it's you, you're,
you just can get yourself
into a more calm state.
It's so much better than I'm frantically
running around and freaking fretting
plus is a, it's a, it
freaks out your opponents.
I would sleep like right in the bleachers.
I just go to sleep right there and
everybody else would be nervous and shit.
And you're sleeping. Exactly.
Do you look at them and that,
I'm supposed to find that guy. The guy
was sleeping right before the fight.
Hell No. Like the first match
studied. I was nuts because you know,
you're in the locker room and there's
the guy sitting next to you goes out for
his match. Come right back.
[inaudible] covered bladder.
They're telling you, okay,
you get ready, you're going
next. And I'm dying. Right.
I just see kid Outta hell.
And she's all like La la, la.
Okay.